I'm Justin react I'm the chief architect
at rogue wave software I focused mostly
on our emerging open-source technologies
that we like to focus on as a company we
provide services and support for
community editions of open source
packages so we do not branch we do not
proprietor eyes we allow you to get the
software from the community and we can
provide you with support in fact this
presentation comes out of a three day
comprehensive training that we do on
nodejs so please feel free to get in
touch with me if you're at all
interested in anything like that and I
promise that is the last sales pitch you
will hear from me so what are we gonna
solve today hold on no just kidding
nobody likes the spinning wheel of doom
or the spinning wheel of hope so we're
gonna talk about how we can use
asynchronous processing to be able to
return requests back to our users faster
a node is inherently asynchronous and
for anybody who hasn't worked in a
language that is inherently asynchronous
it's it's difficult it's gonna be a bit
of a shift in the way that you think
about the way that you're writing your
code but this really is ideal for the
way that things are done now right we're
living in a world of distributed
computing Moore's Law is no longer being
maintained by clock speeds right we're
not seeing huge increases in clock
speeds we are seeing major increases in
the number of cores that we can shove
into a system and we've taken that a
step further and abstracted it all out
and now we're looking at micro services
running in parallel inside of containers
maybe we're spawning 5,000 replicas of a
small machine learning process to spin
up for 20 seconds and read some data and
spin back down and when we're doing all
of that work in parallel we really need
a way to distribute that code and make
that code very atomic anybody who's
familiar with the concept of a 12 factor
app probably if you're working with
containers you're starting to learn some
of those fundamentals
note is actually an ideal language for
doing something like this because it is
inherently asynchronous and it's very
small and very lightweight it is built
on the industry standards and it's been
vetted against thousands of production
systems it is an extremely popular
language right now so what else are we
going to solve this is probably the more
valuable part of working with nodejs
so in the past this is what a
development processor team would look
like right we'll have back-end servers
these are exposing data or services to
front-end applications or front end
servers right and maybe we're writing
these front-end apps in HTML and
JavaScript and CSS and so we have our UI
developers who are familiar with
JavaScript who are writing this part of
the code meanwhile we have another silo
right our back-end servers these are our
back-end api's and back-end systems and
maybe these are getting coded in PHP or
Perl or Java right so this should look
pretty familiar for anybody who's done
any type of development over the last
say 15 years but now we can do this now
we can have a DevOps team only code in
nodejs we have an app farm and our app
is served up but from both the back end
and the front end using JavaScript using
nodejs okay that's an important concept
here right so people who have been good
at doing JavaScript development for a
while can now be more useful at doing
back-end development we can do back-end
and server-side development in
JavaScript which is very useful for the
way that we're sort of converging our
development teams these days so this
allows us to code our front-end and our
back-end using a single language okay
which if you think about this in terms
of agile methodologies and scrum it's a
lot better when we're having a scrum
meeting or something like that and the
technical folks in that meeting are all
capable of understanding and speaking
the same language uh so a little bit of
an overview of the language by the way
stop me at any point if you have a
question I'll do my best
it was created by a guy named Ryan Dahl
in 2009 and really was just created
mostly to deal with these concurrency
issues that we were talking about
before right so when we start thinking
about distributed computing parallel
compute we have to start rethinking the
way that we write code we need that code
to be useful when it's concurrent write
a single JavaScript process is single
threaded by default right we we have one
engine in this case the v8 chrome engine
which is our JavaScript interpreter and
that is a single threaded process but as
we'll see in a moment
Ryan Dahl sort of famously over the
weekend built a layer between the v8
engine and the JavaScript interpreter
and we'll see a picture of that in a
minute but it's built on Chrome's be a
JavaScript engine so again this is
important when nodejs
does not use its own JavaScript engine
right it uses an industry standard
engine but what it really does is layer
some tools in front of that engine that
allow us to do concurrent coding and if
that doesn't make sense right now don't
worry it will in a minute we'll see a
picture all right a single threaded
asynchronous have been driven we can
achieve vertical scale by adding
additional CPU cores and there are
actually conventions within the language
where in just a couple of lines of code
you can tell node.js to fork off a
certain amount of worker processes to
match the number of available processors
on the server in which the code is
running so it can auto scale to an
environment again very ideal for
something like a container environment
where we may not necessarily know the
sizing of that environment and we can
use JavaScript on the browser as well as
in the server which is going to minimize
this mismatch between the environment so
for instance I can do all of my form
validation in a single app as opposed to
having to do form validation on the
front end and then repeat that
validation again on the back end there's
a list of register subscribers which are
basically just node processes and they
are notified when their state changes
okay so you have a pub sub or a topic
like pattern happening between worker
nodes and a master node and that master
node is able to communicate down to the
worker nodes and the worker nodes can
communicate back up to the master using
a topic kind of pub/sub methodology
we also have NPM this used to be called
the node package manager
now you're just supposed to pretend that
the node doesn't stand for node anymore
because this has become a general sort
of JavaScript module repository but the
vast majority of these modules are for
node so anybody who's familiar with you
know maybe pip in Python or Sipan in
perl or new get in dotnet you already
know what NPM is it's just a package
manager for installing dependencies for
your node applications however as of
April of 2019 that number has doubled
and there's no question now that NPM is
not only the fastest-growing module
repository in dependency repository out
there but it's also the largest compared
even to things like maven central right
here for Java right so any Java
developers like myself who are using
maven you're like wow there's a lot of
modules in there yeah well NPM has you
know almost four times as many at this
point and continuing to grow very
quickly so just sort of a general
overview here sort of pros and cons of
using node on the good side of things it
is very lightweight with an extremely
low memory footprint it is a true
cross-platform environment in that
server and client side code can both be
written in the same language as we
talked about before it is very fast it's
asynchronous nature allows it to be just
about as efficient as it possibly can be
it is very popular getting lots of
popularity right now I think I think it
has sort of the same appeal that a
language like Perl had in the late 90s
right this this this shared repository
of well written dependencies but it's
just a little bit more advanced of a
language right now but I think that's
why it's catching fire the way it is
there's already a lot of people who
understand JavaScript and so to make the
transition to node it's just not that
difficult you need to learn a little bit
more about the additional modules that
you can use a node and learn a little
bit about NPM get familiar with some
subjects like semantic versioning and
things like that but overall if you've
done JavaScript development it's pretty
easy
make this transition it is full stack
web development and it's highly
extensible now on the bad side of things
the v8 engine does have a 1.7 memory
gigabyte memory limit okay that means
that we have to have multiple v8 engines
processing in parallel if we want to be
able to use more than 1.7 gigs of memory
within our application and again we can
do that by taking advantage of nodes
clustering functionality so this makes a
vertical scaling challenge but
workarounds do exist module versions can
get a little bit confusing for the most
part people are conforming to semantic
versioning which does make your life
easier but not necessarily over
open-source governance is not flawless
if anybody's familiar with the Left pad
debacle from a few years ago this was a
really big deal there was a module and
note it was like 18 lines of code it was
a very small module and the purpose of
that module was to install to insert
spaces left tab spaces so that you could
align text this thing was used all over
the place
all right tons and tons of apps were
using this the maintainer got angry and
pulled the module off of NPM literally
breaking the internet it's a very
interesting story to read but a good
reminder for everybody that you have to
be careful about your use of open source
you have open source is the best thing
in the world but you have to govern it
you have to manage it you can't just go
wild with it and definitely a learning
curve for developers who maybe aren't
used to dealing with a language that is
inherently asynchronous again it's a
different paradigm
it really feels different when you're
coding you know you expect your code to
just execute one line one line one line
one line like you used to with it with a
synchronous language but in this case
that's not happening at all note is
absolutely gonna skip ahead in your code
and execute things further down even if
it hasn't finished the asynchronous
action that it had before we do have
ways to make this a little bit easier we
have like promises and closures and
things like those patterns if you're
used to that we now have a relatively
new functionality that was introduced in
nekima script 2016 I think called async
await which allows us to pretend that
our code is a little bit more iterative
but but just again you know be aware
that's probably the biggest challenge
for people who are just coming in to
JavaScript into nodejs is wrapping their
heads around this this sort of inherent
asynchronous nature here's a web-enabled
hello world app so again this is a this
is a web enabled one we're actually
creating a back-end web server here okay
so as opposed to just you know printing
something out to the command line or
whatnot
we're actually spinning up a lightweight
web server that's called just basically
the HTTP module that ships with node and
that HTTP module allows us to create a
small HTTP server respond to certain
requests and then you know push what we
want to and of course we tell it to
listen on a particular point report okay
so this is interesting right
this is JavaScript creating a back-end
web server that can service requests all
right that's that's different
Java scripts usually served up by a
back-end server it's not usually the
backend server but again that that's
fundamentally what's different about
this very high level look at the
architecture and what kind of makes this
different and so I said before that that
the creator of node.js Ryan Dahl built
this thing over the weekend well if you
look at the architecture here you can
kind of see how that's possible
right down here this is the v8 chrome
engine this is the actual JavaScript
interpreter this is not written by or
maintained by the node.js community this
is the industry standard JavaScript
interpreter but what have we done here
we have had our we were asking our app
to pass commands through the node engine
this is proprietary to no js' we have
some miscellaneous libraries that we
might hit to access the operating system
okay we've just fundamentally shifted
here from what we're used to with
JavaScript Java scripts not supposed to
be able to know anything about what's
going on at the operating system level
it's sandbox to the browser for security
purposes right you wouldn't want
somebody able to just access or just
just run some arbitrary JavaScript code
on your laptop and give them access to
your operating system but node of course
has to do that because it's running on
the back end so it has some special
libraries specifically for accessing
things about the operating system level
then we have this interesting thing here
called libuv
lid movie is a very fast event loop
it's an event loop that was created in
C++ specifically for nodejs and now it
has found some use in some other
applications as well it's completely
open-source but this is the magic this
is what makes no js' so different I'm
passing commands asynchronously down
into an event loop that event loop is
asynchronously taking actions against
the engine or against the operating
system and returning things back to the
application this is how I'm capable of
having a distributed application that
could actually spawn multiple instances
of the v8 engine to allow this to to
allow the code to execute in parallel
all right so it is literally spawning
off multiple Java side note v8 processes
on the server to go and service a single
JavaScript action okay so you're writing
code and when it executes that action
actually goes into its own isolated v8
engine instance and executes so then
return something so this does a couple
of things for us right so first of all
it makes it very easy for us to be
concurrent in general as long as you can
wrap your head around the asynchronous
semantics of the language
you shouldn't even really have to think
about this it just kind of works that
way it also makes it inherently thread
safe okay because v8 itself is single
threaded and because we're running these
multiple JavaScript actions inside of
isolated separate v8 instances they are
running in their own thread they are
thread safe inherently another way of
looking at the same architecture here's
our app passing commands into v8 here's
the special nodejs bindings and here's
this event queue and it really just is a
queue right it's a loop events come into
the queue the read off the queue and a
loop
if we have a blocking operation like a
database read or a filesystem read then
then this will block but that's okay
because the next event queue can be sent
out into another instance of v8 and
execute in parallel ok so so this is
where the magic happens but if you look
at this and this these two pieces here
were just kind of we're just kind of
stapled on to job
script and that's how Ryan doll was able
to create nodejs in a weekend right he
didn't really write that much code he
just kind of put together some some
libraries that made sense to work
together so you know for the most
popular programming language out there
with the biggest number of dependencies
and modules out of any other language
it's pretty impressive that he really
you know just kind of cranky thing out
over a weekend it's a very smart guy if
you ever get a chance to uh meet him or
talk with him he doesn't like
conferences and he's not a big public
speaker but he does attend some of them
if you get a chance to hear him or speak
with him I I highly recommend it he's a
very smart guy okay so how do we
actually get node going on your system
well kind of depends on your operating
system for you dealing with Linux if
we're using Linux which you know you
probably should be most of these open
source technologies were built with
livings in mind and then maybe back
ported to like a like like a Windows
environment Mac is kind of the exception
right we're running BSD so it's it's
UNIX e-enough it does run on Windows but
you know why there is an official docker
image as well and a standalone shell
script installer so many many options to
install it if you're in a linux
environment this is the easiest way to
do it it's usually just you know yum
install and ojs or apt-get install
node.js once it's been installed we want
to make sure that our package manager
package manager has been installed as
well and we can validate that just by
checking the version of each binary from
the command line so here we are just
saying no - version grind out of old
Bergin and greater than my Mac and then
I were seeing that NPM is installed as
well and if that runs your codes gonna
run because these tools are written in
node.js alright so let's do a quick node
app it's enough theory for the moment
we're just gonna do a super simple
console hello world app and we'll do it
from scratch then we'll execute it on
the command line so I'm just gonna set
the mic down here for a second
so a couple of things to note on this if
you're reminded at all of pearl Python
any of these languages that feel almost
like scripting languages because we can
run them right from the command line
without having to do a build necessarily
right you should be reminded of that
because you can all right now if we have
dependencies and things like that which
most most of our more complex apps are
gonna have then then there is a build
process using NPM but all that build
process really does is download these
modules which which don't have to be
compiled right there just being
interpreted by the by the v8 engine
alright so you get to just kind of just
kind of start real quick without having
to do a whole lot of planning without
having to worry about a bunch of build
files and stuff and for the most part
the the IDE is gonna do you know a lot
of work for you so we're gonna speed up
just a little bit cuz I want to make
sure we can get through all this content
I really like vs code for nodejs
development I really do
Microsoft is surprising everybody right
now this shirt says open-source and it's
a Microsoft the world's changing a
little bit and and BS code is it great
it's a great little IDE totally free and
open source and the preview Edition you
can kooler new functionality so you can
do things like remotely develop the SSH
on a remote server and stuff like that
it's pretty great
terminal integration is essential when
you're building your node apps in fact
youth on that demo I didn't even open an
IDE right I just went right into VI and
just just threw something out there the
built-in debugger works flawlessly with
no J's and so it's really a nice
experience it just it just works and you
do have other options though go with
what's familiar and go with what's
available and is not notepad that's
critical um so we've all got our
preferences when it comes to ideas right
maybe you're already familiar with
something like eclipse that's fine
there's there's no js' tooling for
eclipse maybe you prefer an online IDE
it's something that's integrated already
with docker and maybe gives you a
container environment well you have that
too
just want to make sure that you've met
these basic criteria when you're picking
this ID ID you really want the debugger
obviously you want syntax highlighting
you want it to support what's called es
lint for those that don't know Java
Script is not really Java Script it's
the specifications is actually called
ECMAScript or ECMO Script and that's
what that es comes from do you want es
lint and if ever use lint before to
clean up your code or to check your code
for syntax it's basically what it's
doing we want terminal integration we
want to M integration we want code
completion with intellisense we want to
beautifier we do want docker integration
these days you know it's just a lot
easier to get started with with docker
we want node modules integration which
we'll look at in a minute and we want
our source control integration hopefully
we're using git or something like that
and we're not just you know saving our
our program in a zip or something but
you do have some other options when you
want to look at an IDE this one is
actually pretty cool I have to say this
cloud9 IDE it's completely online
and so it's kind of like kind of cloudy
basically all your your your coats gonna
get sort up in the cloud but it does
have to get integration and all that
kind of stuff you can push all your code
out to your github live preview
jetbrains if you like the IntelliJ
experience if you're a Java developer
JetBrains does produce one that's
similar called webstorm for nodejs
Komodo and then node clips if you like
eclipse then you can just get the
node.js plugins for Eclipse so plenty of
options here I just really like vs code
so we're gonna focus on that we have a
bunch of BS code extensions for no GS
when we search for it up here and so
you've got our debug and really just
adjust up just a bunch of stuff and
there's a whole lot of plugins for the
various frameworks and dependency
libraries that we can use with notes so
things like view j/s or angularjs or
react there's a lot of tooling that's
built in for that as well I have another
talk on react which unfortunately didn't
get accepted at this one but I will be
giving that talk at the OSS summit in
San Diego in August start with at least
no debug in the node.js extension gone I
take time to explore what's out there
though in vs code we have a launch file
that's specific to vs code alright this
has nothing to do with no J as this is
telling vs code how to launch our app
but this is essential if we want to be
able to debug our app okay the launch
configuration is controlled through a
JSON file called launch JSON
good launches and it basically just
describes the environment bootstrap
information for the app if I want to set
some environment variables maybe this is
where I would do that but it is
essential for debugging because your app
is gonna get more complex you're gonna
need some stuff set up in your
environment before you can run your app
like an environment variable or whatnot
maybe you're using OAuth and you need a
client key I don't know you're gonna be
storing stuff in an environment variable
and it won't launch properly without
that environment variability being set
so you need to tell BS code what the
environment should look like and you do
that and this launch data JSON file so
let's take a quick look at the debugger
we can get coordinated here okay so
we'll start I'm setting breakpoints just
like I normally would in any IDE we'll
go ahead and set to you one at the very
beginning even though it's kind of
useless and then one afterwards so that
we can check and introspect the contents
of our variable okay when you get
started with node you're gonna spend a
lot of time in here all right and in
this debugger because it's very easy to
look at the way that the nodejs object
notation works and it's very easy to
kind of see how functions like every
object is actually treated like a
function functions our first class
citizens in nodejs so i can pass them
and i can set them and and all that get
more into that i have an advanced talk
on this so let's just run this let's
look at our launch configuration okay
so we stopped at our first breakpoint
and we can already see that we've got
some useful stuff in here and i realize
it's kind of hard to see let me so I'm
not gonna go into the contents of all of
this right now but I do kind of
recommend you poke around in here
because you're gonna get to learn a lot
about what nodes actually doing in the
background for you but we can see that
we have to find our constant it just
hasn't been set yet
currently undefined so let's move to our
next breakpoint and great we can see
that our variable has actually been
populated at this point we could
introspect it we can set a watch point
on it really anything that you'd expect
to be able to do in a debugger we can do
here
all right pick up the pace a little bit
all right so we've seen just a quick
hello world that you can get started
with very easily and now you've had a
little preview of what we can do in
terms of our developer our debugger in
our IDE so this is the basic life cycle
of an ode app we're gonna create and
clone an SCM repo hopefully again
hopefully we're using source control
like good people right but if not you
can just create a folder if you're gonna
use get you know set up your ignore
files and what not you want to
initialize the project this is the best
practice I haven't done that yet the
very last demo shows that but NPM an it
will set up you a file called package
JSON that we're about to see and that's
like your build file that's where all
your dependency information is housed as
well as some meta information about the
app itself NPM and it will set that up
for you automatically and a lot of IDE
plugins and extensions will do that too
then you just get to it start coding
commit as normal and then build so in
our target production environment we're
gonna run this NPM install that's gonna
download and all of our necessary
dependencies when we see our package
JSON file in a minute this NPM install
will actually go out to the NPM
repository pull all the modules down
which is effectively the build process
for note because again we're not
compiled in anything that's this is what
the NPM and that kind of looks like so
you see it's gonna prompt you for some
information things like a git repo
author your license which should always
be GPL 3 and then it's gonna generate
your package JSON file based on that we
just talking through all this ok so now
let's turn this into a proper node
application or what we should really be
calling a node module even large node
applications are still considered a node
module right
it's just comes with your node tooling
right if you've installed node you
should have the NPM tooling as well
that I have this script in there I'm
just gonna kind of leave all this
blanket but this right here is the
package.json file all right so let's say
it's okay yes when we cat it out then
this is what we have now I in just a
minute I'm gonna kind of rush through a
little bit cuz I want to see I want to
show you the very last part which is
working with external modules in NPM but
all of that dependency data is held in
that package JSON file which again looks
like this so our our apps can use
dependencies or modules remember
everything in nodejs is a module
technically most open source languages
these days are going to have a set of
modules that can be added to a project
notice no different you can also create
your own modules whether privately or
freely available and the mbm
repositories would actually provides
these and it could be used to add
dependencies to a project by again using
this npm install command but it's not
npm install blank like doing the whole
build like we saw a second ago this is
actually installing a particular module
so let's see what that looks like so
let's add a little color to our app
there's a module for node just called
colors and it's for doing colors like
when an z and z generated color codes in
the terminal you want it to be readable
and even fun and as you start working
with more and more nodejs apps on the
command line you'll find that people
actually do care about this like they're
putting cool little UTF icons and stuff
in their code and put in colors and and
everything
if we run npm - save that will actually
make sure this module is saved to
package JSON so that when we distribute
it to our production environment and we
run npm install those modules will be
downloaded into our environment so here
we're just saying npm install - - save
colors and then in our code we can now
require the color's module and now we
can use this syntax to make something
like red and underlined so let's take a
look at that real fast and then we'll
wrap it up
[Music]
notice all the pretty colors okay now
what did that do we've got our package
JSON file and now we have this new
folder called node modules as well and
this is unsurprisingly where our module
is just downloaded to so if we do a
quick LS in here we can see that the
colors module downloaded and if we pick
this up it's just another nodejs
module it's just written a note if we
look at our package JSON file we can see
that we now have a dependencies section
in here and it automatically picked a
version for me and I can use semantic
versioning syntax here if I want to
enforce some stuff and then at this
point if we run npm install even if we
don't have that not node modules folder
it'll go and download that module for us
again
[Music]
here
all right so we just imported a
dependency and use the module and that
actually wraps us up so what did we
learn today we learned that you should
carry your clicker with you when you
leave podium nodejs is a language that
focuses on concurrency and unified
development under a single language
dependencies are assisted through the
node package manager
which is no longer called the node
package manager it is asynchronous by
default a lot of ideas exist
you should initialize your projects
using NPM init you can install modules
with NPM install they're built from
package JSON when we install in a
production environment and they're
included in variables using the require
command but there's still a lot to learn
so go learn about understanding
asynchronous coding it just takes
practice get to know the events and
streams inside of node learn about
functional programming this is very much
functional programming mastery IDs
debugger and start exploring other
modules and finally feel free to reach
out to me I do get lonely and you I
promise you I will accept your LinkedIn
or Twitter or any of that I do get a
little political on Twitter though so if
you're easily offended by hippy politics
then maybe don't go there
that's it thanks